we begin this half-hour with new
questions in the apparent poisoning
of a one-time Russian double agent
British soldiers are being deployed and
hazmat teams are scouring the community
of Salsbury this weekend in what's being
treated as a counterterrorism
investigation Roxana Saberi has more
from London this morning Roxana good
morning good morning
Sergei skree Paul and his daughter
remain in critical condition and one of
the responding officers is in serious
condition
today the British government will hold
an emergency meeting on what authorities
are treating as attempted murder
around 180 military troops and chemical
weapons experts are searching for
evidence in the southern English city of
Salisbury a sign that the investigation
into the poisoning of the former Russian
spy is expanding at a local cemetery
where Sergey scruples wife is buried
investigators wore hazmat suits and
placed a tent over a memorial to
scruples late Sun authorities also
cordoned off the house where scree Paul
lived and where he and his daughter
Yulia were on Sunday after going out to
lunch and visiting a pub the pair were
found on a park bench unconscious the
UK's Home Secretary has said the two
were exposed to a nerve agent this was
attempted murder in the most cruel and
public way detectives are trying to
discover how the toxin was administered
where it was made and who made it
University College London professor
Andrei Acela the very nature of the
agents is pointing towards estate it is
only ever states that have used these
kinds of materials British authorities
say it's too early to lay blame but
suspicions are falling on Russia
skree Paul came to the UK as part of a
prisoner exchange negotiated with Moscow
in 2010 having done jail time in Russia
for spying for Britain Russian media
have ridiculed suggestions that the
Kremlin was behind Sunday's attack and
on Friday Russian Foreign Minister
Sergei Lavrov said according to our
Western partners we are guilty of
everything that is wrong on this planet
she's stupid
police say government scientists have
identified the nerve agent used but are
not yet
saying what it was authorities say there
is no risk to the general public but as
you can imagine Alix there is still a
lot of concern here a lot of intrigue
Roxana Saberi in London thanks Roxana